una visita en la casa blanca que podría
ser preámbulo de una nueva era
estratégica para la otan el presidente
de finlandia saúl y ninis pto y la
primera ministra sueca magdalena
anderson se reunieron con el presidente
joe biden de gira tras entregar sus
solicitudes para entrar en la alianza
atlántica en rayas azules que el
agresión james de sobre la agresión rusa
a gran escala contra un vecino soberano
y democrático fue un momento decisivo
para suecia y mi gobierno ha llegado a
la conclusión de que la seguridad del
pueblo sueco estará mejor protegida
dentro de la alianza de la otan
es una decisión aplaudida por el
mandatario estadounidense
y hoy me enorgullece asegurarles que
cuentan con el respaldo total total y
completo de los eeuu de américa hoy mi
administración está presentando el
congreso de eeuu informes sobre la
atención al otan de ambos países para
que el senado pueda pasar rápidamente a
asesorar y consentir el tratado pero es
necesario que los 30 aliados de la otan
den el sí y turquía lanzó su veto
argumentando que éstos protegen
terroristas los nórdicos están abiertos
al diálogo
como aliados de la otan nos
comprometeremos con la seguridad de
turquía al igual que turquía se
comprometerá con nuestra seguridad nos
tomamos el terrorismo en serio el futuro
geoestratégico de suecia y finlandia
está ligado al de los kurdos de turquía
y siria según ankara protegen a miembros
del pkk el partido de los trabajadores
del kurdistán declarado como terrorista
por turquía y las jbg filias del pkk en
el norte de siria y aliado de eeuu en la
lucha contra el estado islámico ankara
estaría condicionando su veto a
concesiones sobre este tema y también ha
hablado sobre el embargo de armas de
ambos países tras la ofensiva turca
sobre el norte de siria en 2019